at what point do you sign on to a movie
in most cases he depends I think now I
rather sign on from from the very
beginning even from the script stage so
if the directors that worked before like
with with Todd all the directors that I
had a chance to work before I die they
send me the script and I talk about the
script in that sort of if they want
really specific ideas i'll give them
ideas are just read descriptions like
this is great or and from then on
getting Paul but sometimes or it could
be the first first time we work on the
person I would still love to get
involved at least in be cutting while
they're shooting because then you can
give them or you can give them feedback
just just as close as possible and as
much as possible as an error I want to
be there and want to be involved I want
to just just be part of the of the
creative process so they're giving you
dailies and then you're going in and
sort of shaping that scene yeah okay on
Carol d was shooting in Cincinnati my
cutting room was in New York City so
they were so they were shooting one day
they were shifted the scene them that
the negative there was really super 16
so the negatives come to New York they
got scanned to 4k gets my cutting room
and I will cut and Todd doesn't like to
watch days it just does not watch daily
so I would watch the footage and I would
just give him feedback either email text
or be like okay this is this is great
the ship and because it was being shot
in super 16 so there are things that you
don't see any more so if there was any
scratch the negative if there was like
soft focus if there was hair and the
gate stuff like oh those were film
things that you have to pay attention
out of that on Carol so that's what I
was doing and then I would just assemble
as it came in what I was seeing I got
that day I cut that scene and I cut the
whole film that day that would cut the
whole film when it was finished shooting
and then Todd came in after you shot
here to calibrate he came back did very
detailed notes shut SAT by himself
watching the whole the footage to detail
notes gave it to me and then I cut the
film based on the notes so and then he
came in and we start working together
that one
how common is that for a director not
want to not want to see the dailies and
why what is the logic behind that I'm
not really sure the logic behind for
Todd I think he just doesn't want to get
chu into his head about how things are
working he wants to focus on building
that world as he's directing and
creating the visual world in every
possible way no in the photography but
with production design and constant
design and everything so he wants to be
mersin that world not to be thinking
how's this going to cut here this is it
here so it kind of is trusting me to be
okay you got it so just keep doing it
worry I think that their directors that
the few directors they actually don't
want to don't want to see anything but
most of the times they want to take a
look even they ask and it's going to do
can kind of sing together Academy as
it's going they were there very
interesting to know how is shaping up
I'm sure there's different ones that
want to be right there with you at all
times and then others that give you a
lot of freedoms yeah I like to have the
director in the room with me as much as
possible I really do because i think
that the dialogue and how are you you're
building and creating creating the
scenes we talked up talking then i can
do something on the avid any of you hit
play just on the side now looking at me
work but doing something else and then i
can just right away be like okay how
about this take okay I have an idea how
about this so I think there's a fluidity
to have the director there and then just
I think he's stimulating too because I
can if the director is not there and I
understand sometimes the ref is just
bored out of their minds to be in the
cutting room because watching somebody
cut is not it's not that easy because
it's such an internal process but I like
that you you being like you fire is
always been stoked in a way because you
always have in that conversation if the
director leaves and I've done something
I had to wait for him to come back
sometimes it's just sort of like it's
too much of a the then that the flow may
just be too slow so having him around
and Todd and out our lives to be in the
cutting room so it's it's perfect it's
great is there anyone else that comes
into the cutting room as well is it just
the director uh it's just a director I
mean unless he invites i think add came
in a couple of
times and while I was cutting and Todd
wasn't around and and I had a start is
ok to show stuff to add in touches of
course you can come in and but we don't
my assistant it's another it's the
person that I showed the cards and I
want to feed like immediate feedback i
come from my assistant and then it's
something like if Christine would come
in or she never does or we want to show
people we do but most of the time is
just just us just the two of us building
it like finishes amount that way
you